wollen nun noch einmal nach beirut
schauen denn von dort haben uns seit
dienstagabend natürlich unzählige videos
erreicht viele von ihnen zeigen die
dramatische explosion und eines ist ganz
besonders in den sozialen netzwerken
geteilt worden
es zeigt den eigentlich schönsten tag
ihres lebens man sieht eine braut sie
posiert kurz nach der hochzeit und dann
hier die druckwelle was genau da
passiert ist und wie sich das für das
brautpaar die frisch getrauten
angeführter das möchte ich nun natürlich
wissen das brautpaar ist bei meinem
kollegen jan frederik landshausen in
beirut genauso vielen dank nele wir sind
hier in beirut direkt am hafen also
unweit entfernt von der explosion
und hier hatte israels die braut eine
hochzeit feiern wollen ihre
hochzeitsfeier
wir stehen jetzt vor dem hotel das
völlig zerstört ist hier sind überall
glassplitter die fenster sind raus sei
hier mal sehr luxuriös und schöne aus so
sieht's jetzt nicht mehr aus und wie das
ganze passiert ist wie sie das erlebt
hat das fragen wir die braut am besten
jetzt mal selbst steht direkt neben
israel
ok also vielleicht nochmal einmal
zusammenfassen sie hat drei jahre sich
auf diesen tag hier gefreut
dann ist es kannten sie rauch gesehen
im hintergrund und dann kam es zu der
explosion und innerhalb weniger sekunden
hat sich das ja alles wie sie sagt in
eine geisterstadt verwandelt leute haben
geschrien hat ein panik sind umher
gerannt und sie hat eben selber gesagt
das war für sie ein albtraum
eine frage vielleicht noch also sie sagt
das ist natürlich wahnsinnig schrecklich
für sie kann jetzt natürlich nicht mehr
feiern das ist jetzt kein schöner moment
mehr für sie und alles was sie kann nun
tun will ist ihrem land zu helfen und
damit an nele zurück zu dir nach berlin